now in the united states the democratic
party convention
has kicked off with a rousing speech
from michelle obama the wife of former
president barack obama
now this year's convention is unlike any
other because of the coronavirus
pandemic the event is being held
online without crowds or confetti the
democrats will
formally nominate joe biden as their
candidate for president
to take on republican incumbent donald
trump in
the november election
dw stacy bivins is with us to take a
closer look at the convention hi stacy
thanks for joining us
what did day one tell us about what the
democrats are trying to achieve here
well they're trying to portray their
candidate joe biden as an everyman
somebody that everybody can relate to
and somebody who has enough big ideas
where he has
a big tent so we had
progressive democrats moderate democrats
disenchanted
republicans who voted for trump all
recognized on this very first day
to prove that he is the kind of person
that is
empathetic that you can relate to and
more importantly he can relate to you
and your struggles all right so a lot of
people really rallying
around joe biden let's take a look now
what a lot of people are calling
the highlight of day one of the
convention namely michelle obama
speaking let's listen to what she said
we have to vote for joe biden in numbers
that cannot be ignored because right now
folks who know they cannot win fair and
square at the ballot box are doing
everything they can
to stop us from voting they're closing
down polling places in minority
neighborhoods
they're purging voter rolls they're
sending people
out to intimidate voters and they're
lying
about the security of our ballots stacy
michelle obama not mincing her words
there this is being called really a
searing message
not only to endorse joe biden but to
take on president trump i mean what did
you think of what she said that's right
what she did is unprecedented because
usually a firmer first lady
speaks kindly of the candidate and not
disparaging the incumbent but she went
for the jugular
and you know she's known for this um the
saying that she had in the 2016 dnc
when they go low we go high and what she
meant by that was that you just don't
sit around
and be beat up you have to defend
yourself and you have to
base your votes and your on actions and
on truth
and she says in that truth is that
donald trump cannot meet this moment
he simply cannot be who we need him to
be for us
and then she said it is what it is
basing off of what he said about the
coronavirus numbers
um and then she she gave a warning like
saying that
things could couldn't could get worse so
if people are sitting thinking that they
can
vote for another candidate to
you know um to protest
because biden isn't as progressive as
they want she's like look
stop playing games this is serious this
is the real deal and
donald trump is a clear and present
danger and we need to take action well
her words as we said seem to really
resonate with a lot of people and there
were a lot of reactions
trending on twitter i think we have some
of the tweets here some of the reactions
uh to michelle obama's speech let's see
if we can pull them up here one
person saying i've just never seen a
political speech
like michelle obama's tonight it's a
singular thing
and then there's another tweet here from
someone saying and another concise
uh enough said that we can cancel the
next
three nights
yeah i mean she spoke with a kind of
calm and a kind of authority and a kind
of trust she spoke as a mom
who's worried about the kind of example
donald trump is setting for kids
she spoke as a minority who has seen
black brown
people and their allies marching in the
streets pushing for justice
and she spoke as somebody who was an
expert who knows what it takes
to run the white house right you know
she was the first lady and she knows joe
biden was there so she spoke to his
character
something she doubled down on i want to
ask you about another speech we heard
we heard from one of joe biden's biggest
adversaries in the primaries bernie
sanders who delivered
a ringing endorsement of biden here's
what he said
joe biden will end the hate and division
trump has created he will stop the
demonization of immigrants
the coddling of white nationalists the
racist dog whistling
the religious bigotry and the ugly
attacks
on women you know stacey we really heard
bernie sanders talk a lot about
policy and and this was important wasn't
it to particularly the left wing of the
democratic party who
really want to make sure that they are
united behind
one candidate yeah i think that he came
out stronger than he did for hillary
right when she
won the the democratic nomination he was
saying look we need to coalesce together
we need to first get donald trump out of
the white house and then we can
push on with our progressive agenda but
none of that will be possible
if donald trump is re-elected all right
well certainly a strong message there
from bernie sanders what do you think we
can look for in the rest of the
convention
we will see more progressive people
speaking andrew um
what ioc will be speaking sorry
alexandria ocasio-cortez
thank you and so she'll be speaking uh
tonight
and former president bill clinton will
be speaking tonight
people are worried that maybe joe biden
won't be as dynamic
as first lady obama
but um but he's but they say that he's
the man for the job and so we just need
to trust his character more than his
performance is what they're saying
our reporter stacey bippins looking into
this for us thank you so much
you're welcome sue